MARK MIRCHANDANI:
This week, we're
talking about Kubernetes,
cloud native, and networking.
Welcome to "This Week in
Cloud," where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
We recently talked about how
Kubernetes apps in the GCP
Marketplace make it
easier to find and deploy
commercial or open-source apps.
Managing or building
Kubernetes applications
takes a lot of
effort, which is why
Kubernetes operators
help standardize and make
the process easier.
The application Custom
Resource Definition
includes a standard API for
creating, viewing, and managing
applications in Kubernetes,
giving you well-defined ways
to interact with and
manage your deployed apps.
Read more about these
Kubernetes operators
and see them in action
on the GCP Marketplace.
After all, Kubernetes
has played a major role
in helping developers
build cloud native.
But there's many projects
that have been redeveloped
and released in the open-source
community, such as Istio,
Knative and Kubeflow.
Check out this blog post
that talks more about
what these tools do, and
how they can help you
build a cloud-native future.
For a more traditional
application,
cloud native can sometimes
feel overwhelming.
If you're familiar with any
application that's one part web
server and one part database,
such as a traditional AMP app,
check out this new
solution for migrating
your two-tier
application to GCP.
It presents all the
central planning questions
you'll need to have
answered ahead of time,
then makes the case for various
compute and database options.
If you want to learn
more about migrating,
there's no better
place to start.
Looking to do some
serious networking?
It takes a lot for
Google's global network
to handle billions
of users a day.
And that's the same network
you get on your Google Cloud
projects.
Check out this
networking deep dive
on the different
load-balancing options
and how Google makes them work.
Keep up to date with more
networking deep dives
on the Google Cloud blog,
and networking end-to-end end
on the GCP YouTube channel.
If you want to read more
about these announcements,
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas,
leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.